[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning it's time to
bring you some of the stories that we
call talk at the table this morning in
vlad's in pole position so we were
moaning and groaning about this going
into commercial uh my talk at the table
is a warning
a warning for people who share their
netflix password why were we moaning
because are we breaking the law
we're breaking the law but uh
streaming giant says now
it is testing a program that will charge
subscribers an additional fee
for users outside of their household
until now as everyone knows netflix has
turned a blind eye yeah to whatever it
is that you're doing
which is for some people sharing
passwords but now it says it is
impacting their ability to invest in
great new tv and films
netflix is a multi-billion dollar
company one of the largest i love these
in the world i love that rationale it's
it's help it's hurting their investment
it's sort of like this hurts you more
than yes it hurts you more than it hurts
us so netflix plans to launch the fees
which are about three dollars in the
next few weeks they're going to roll it
out in chile costa rica and peru i think
it's fair you know you do yes i mean it
is we're not supposed to share passwords
but i know lots of people that do
but so i think it's there i think it's
more like you know people share like for
your elderly parents who maybe don't
know how to set a netflix account up or
a streaming account and you go hey mom
dad let me show you you can just use
mine and now you raised me for 18 years
saying we want to get paid right
it's totally fair it's gonna be harder
to track down all the password sharing
but i